In this lesson, we're going to take a look at texture and material optimizations.
So let's get started.
So textures should be treated based on priority and the shot.
And that really goes for pretty much everything you put into Unreal.
You have to think of it as a real-time tool and not an offline renderer tool for those
that are working in film.
So your final pixel highest resolution textures should be used on Hero Objects.
This is the same rule that we have with games.
So for ICVFX, less is more.
For resolution to gain performance, and the highest is not always needed based on focus.
Basically, your actor is the focus and everything behind that actor, if it's directly behind
them, needs to have a higher resolution.
But if it's farther back, you can lower the resolution.
I'll give you an example.
If I had a mountain range and my texture for it was 8K, and it's in the way in the distance,
I don't need 8K.
I can lower that to an easy 4K or even 2K if I'm using fog to hide some of the missing
details.
So that's actually really helpful to consider and think of things on that level.
For large scenes that have lots of high resolution textures, say you have a terrain, and maybe
you're using virtual production, less of ICVFX, but more of a kind of maybe even a final pixel
scenario, you can use virtual texturing so that only the highest resolution of the texture
is loaded per where the camera and the focus series are at.
In Unreal, we also have mitmap control.
So if you run into problems with blurring or repeating patterns such as more, you can
actually adjust that.
Let me go ahead and take a look at that in Unreal.
It's a bit of a review, but hopefully it'll let you know or remind you where things are
located.
So let's go ahead and double click on this particular texture.
In this texture, let's go and zoom out a bit.
You'll see in the details for it that we have a mitgen settings.
This is where we can do some corrective work.
If we're noticing there's some blurring or a moray pattern happening.
We can also tell what texture group we want this object to be in.
This helps with a bit of compiling and maybe a little bit more centric for games for the
final packaging.
But for the most part, you can actually have Unreal kind of skip a step of picking through
your compiling of your object and knowing your intentions.
And if anything is dependent upon that can be a bit helpful.
So those are some things to consider.
Let's go back to the slides and look at a few more things.
Another tool that we have at our fingertips is a thing called edit via property matrix.
Now this property matrix makes it so that we can lock down resolution to a particular
type or I should say number.
If you're noticing that things are getting a little bit heavy into your scene, let's jump
into Unreal and I'll point out where those things are at.
So several of these textures will say are maybe a little bit too high.
I can go and select them.
We'll do shift and click here.
I'm going to right click in here and go to my asset actions.
And then I'm going to go to my edit selection in property matrix.
Once you open up the property matrix, you have access to many things.
One of them you can look at the texture overall and you can see, hey, you know, I want to
change the tiling method, kind of a little bit of a sweeping control there.
We even have importing settings here and we have adjustments.
You'll see there's a simple layout.
This is basically an expansion of the details that you get in the texture we were just in.
We also have compression here that we can control as well as LOD level of detail.
So if we open this up just a little bit more, you can see all these details.
You'll see right here a maximum texture size.
So we can lock that down and we can do it for as many as we need or have selected.
So that's actually pretty helpful for a bit of optimization.
So here are some notes for a bit more linear content leaning towards ICVFX.
If you're not using decals, make sure that you disable them in your project settings
because they do use a little bit of memory.
And don't use video elements as they cost.
Use flip books instead, animated through a material parameter or EXR.
So we have a fairly new system which has been updated for EXR where you can actually use
high resolution EXR images and put them on a plate, which is actually pretty great.
Both are good methods to have synchronized animated sequences.
So I recommend that if at all possible, especially if you're working with ICVFX because the video,
the latter is a bit more cumbersome to actually get going in that particular scenario.
For elements in the background, you can bake textures also, but check with production leads
to see if changes may be needed later.
It's not always used, but that's basically due to the on fly edits you get when you're
on stage.
Since going backwards is tricky, so make sure that you maybe keep the original copy with
you.
So this is up to you and best to make a copy of all items whenever possible.
And you'll see a bake within the material itself.
You can actually bake them automatically, those textures.
You can also use virtual texturing for large scenes for overhead.
Let me show you a little bit of that in just a second.
But also you can also pack RGB into UV channels.
We go over this in some of our foundational material classes, but that's pretty simple.
You actually will be making the texture have different channels and in it you can have
roughness, you can have an alpha.
The only problem with that is you have to think ahead of time of what you want.
So let's go and pop into Unreal real quick and I'll show you the virtual texturing a
bit of what you can do.
So let's go ahead and pick on this particular texture.
I'm going to go and get my magnifying glass here and say these three textures, I need
to make them be a bit more virtual texture friendly.
Now before you do that though, you don't want to make sure in your project settings that
you actually have it on.
I have it on, so I'm kind of cheating.
So let's go to a virtual texturing and you'll see that I have enabled my virtual texturing
support.
Really handy.
Now it's good to turn these on too, especially if you're having problems with your viewers
and they're not coming up.
They can support you a bit.
So virtual texturing is active and I'm going to go in here and now with these three selected
I can right click and I can convert these to virtual textures.
Now when you do, it's going to ask you what resolution you want and it's going to give
you a whole list.
This gets pretty tricky.
So you have to figure out what is the texture that you need and want and you need to find
it and that way if you don't want to do all of them, you have the option and you can
choose what that texture size threshold is going to be.
It's actually pretty handy to do this, especially for large worlds that you're dealing with.
And again, how virtual texturing works is it only renders what is needed and the highest
fidelity images based on the positioning of your camera.
So it's like virtual shadow maps, virtual texturing and even Nanite works like that,
but on a triangle basis.
Now we won't dive too much into this part, but I want to remind everyone about these
nodes, especially if you're working with ray tracing and it also works with path tracer,
where you can actually use a ray trace quality switch replace.
You can either do that or you can make a parameter, a switch parameter.
Now that switch parameter allows you to switch between a texture or a simple number that
you're using, but the quality switch replace when it comes to ray tracing does this for
you automatically based on where you're at in the scene.
And it just gives you that nice automatic switch between a high quality and a low quality
based on where you are at with your camera and your position in the world.
So again, here's the static switch parameter option.
And this basically is active.
Once you create an instance material, you'll be able to see this and you can turn it on
or off being able to have another scalar parameter in there to be able to control
things, the values of each one that is up to you.
This is covered in other classes, but I did want to put a reminder in here because this
is important to consider, especially if you feel that your texture resolution isn't always
needed in a particular area, such as rough or simple metallic, you can actually switch those.
So things to consider and really think about when you're being deterministic for your shots,
specifically for IC VFX.
So your parent materials need to be used with instances.
This is really important because then you're actually not recompiling that material over
and over again, and you can make an instant change with that instance material.
Kind of a lot of instances in that almost got a tongue twister there.
So we have also you want to make sure you use material functions as much as possible.
So these will make it so you don't have a noodle fest, make things cleaner and allow
you to get where you need to go.
And you can connect your instances to these and so forth and just make things a lot easier
overall.
You also can use material layers.
It's up to you.
I don't recommend using substrate at this time.
We do put a warning on that because it is still in beta.
It's not ready for prime time.
Also, when you go to substrate, you can't go back to regular materials.
So it's kind of an all or nothing.
But you can use your material layers in this particular case with Unreal default.
And I didn't want to make that mention though for substrate because substrate gives you some
options in there for that to keep things a little bit cleaner when it comes to layers.
And I didn't want you to get too excited looking at material layers.
Try to stay within old school at this time with 5.3 and a couple of versions coming up.
But substrates almost there.
Not quite there yet.
The goal is for better real time performance.
You have to think of it this way.
What is the best performance you can get for that camera for ICVFX and your hero objects
are the priority.
You can bake textures if you want, but keep in mind, you can't actually make those changes
once you've baked.
So you might want to make sure if you are going to bake that you at least have the originals
nearby so that if the director does change his mind, you can quickly switch them out.
Keep higher textures and material complexity limited to hero objects like we mentioned
before and use material parameter collections to help simplify material control, which we
cover in some of our material classes.
Final pixel parent materials need to be used with instances.
Very important.
Less worry with frame rate on less editing.
So you're not worried about frame rate so much.
You're looking for the final results.
But again, looking for better final results requires that you also do keep in mind the
concept of hero objects.
Again higher textures for hero objects as we said before, use material functions to group
common features together and can use material layers.
Again, this is a new system and you can use it when necessary.
Use material parameter collections to help simplify material control.
Here's a few links that will help you get in the right direction.
And if you want to dive in deeper, here's a few more additional resources and a link
for game optimization.
If you want to dive in there, some more resources here for optimization and some credits here
of some of the people that I've worked with to pull this all together.
That's it with this one.
I hope you enjoyed this series of courses.
In the next video, we're going to do a recap of everything we've talked about.
Thanks again.